hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be showing from the freestyle
chess goat challenge 2024 which is a
well just a fancy way of saying they've
met up in in a village in Northern
Germany to play some fishal random chess
uh but a joking aside it is actually
very nice this is the this is the place
sorry not that those are the rules this
this is the place that I'm talking about
the visen house private nature luxury
resort uh situated in nor Northern
Germany so you can see the venue really
uh beautiful scenery and these are the
rules as this is Fisher random chest so
all the pieces are scrambled uh and the
the format and setup as this is the
first game we are showing so it's going
to be around Robin uh first they're
going to be uh two days of Rapid so 25
minutes for the game plus 10 seconds per
move according to the A5 of the FED laws
of Chess and then for the quarterfinal
semi-finals and finals uh two games
standard 90 minutes plus 40 moves plus
30 minutes for the rest of the game
additional 30 seconds per move so two
days of Rapid chess and then six more
days of of classical chess that's how it
that's how it's going and the two days
of Rapid chest are basically
qualifications to uh you know see uh uh
how you will start and who you will play
against in in the classical time format
uh so it's um very strong event features
some of the strongest players in the
world uh let's check it out first game
we are showing GES versus Magnus Carlson
from round two let's check it out GES
with the white pieces opens with Pawn to
F4 now uh before we check out the game I
would just like to mention for those of
you who are watching for the first time
you might have a question if the pieces
are all scrambled up can you Castle in
this variant of chest yes you can castle
and the way you Castle is uh well look
at the king the king is on C1 you can
still Castle Queen's side and you can
also still Castle King's side for
example the castle King side you would
have to clear everything in between the
king and the Rook so the two knights and
the two Bishops here and you will just
uh Castle King side and the King will go
to a square G1 where the king will
usually go in normal chest when King
castles King side and The Rook will go
to F1 where the Rook usually goes when
you Castle King side in regular chest so
that's how you do it and that's
basically it it's it's uh you know
applies um same for Queen side uh once
once you Castle Queen side the king will
REM you have to just move the queen uh
and the Bishop from D1 because once you
Castle the king will remain on C1
because that's where the king would go
if you castled Queen side in regular
chest and The Rook will come to D1 where
it would come if you castled in regular
chest that's pretty much it other than
that uh everything else is exactly the
same and uh of course there are no
openings here unless you're able to know
all 960 positions and you know come up
with openings for all of them and
remember them then yes there are
openings even in chest 960 but I don't
think uh you know people can can do that
maybe some some maybe you know maybe
these guys can but I don't know uh so
let's check it out and here we have Pawn
to F4 by GES Pawn to C6 by Magnus
opening up the queen putting pressure on
that F4 Pawn right away G3 defending and
now Pawn to F5 he's opening up the light
Square Bishop maybe preparing Bishop um
to D5 to go after the Rook on H1 Knight
to F3 and now Bishop to B6 countering
the bishop on G1 uh Pawn to C3 preparing
to expand in the center with D4 and D4
and Magnus trades Bishops Bishop
captures on G1 Rook captures and Knight
to D6 maybe thinking about planting a
knight on e4 uh so D3 and pawn to B5 we
have Pawn to E4 and now F captures on e4
D captures on e4 uh and the queen to B6
putting pressure on that Rook on G1 so
if the Knight moves you might lose the
Rook uh Knight one to D2 and now Pawn to
G5 trying to mess up um gu's Pawn
structure here or you force him to move
the Knight and then you pick up the Rook
so here F captures on G5 G cash doesn't
mind uh Knight to E6 developing while
putting more pressure on the G5 pawn and
now Rook back to E1 uh we have Bishop to
F7 and now Bishop to B3 and uh here it's
a really good example of castling in a
fish random chest you can still Castle
Queen side if you Castle Queens side
this is what would happen and if you
Castle King side then this is what would
happen you just uh put them in a
position they would normally go into in
in regular chess and this is exactly
what Magnus played uh and it's one of
the things that you really have to
figure out when you're playing Fisher
random chess because okay if you look at
the position now it's a pretty standard
position it doesn't uh look any
different from any position that you
would have um in regular chess uh but
it's easy to forget that your opponent
you know sometimes you're deep in
thought you're thinking about attacking
that King on C8 it's easy to forget that
you your opponent can just Castle King
side you know you shift all of your
attention to the queen side said you
move everything to the queen side and
then he's just uh I'm out of here and
it's it's I mean it does happen so here
we have Queen to C2 developing the queen
also with ideas of castling and now just
Pawn to A5 Magnus wants to play Pawn to
A4 here uh Pawn to E5 attacking the
Knight and now while this does open up
this diagonal for the queen it also
opens up this diagonal for magnus's
Bishop so he first plays Bishop to G6
attacks the queen and now gkes frees up
the B3 Square for the Queen with Tempo
Bishop captures Pawn captures and queen
B3 attacking the pawn on E6 but Magnus
just plays Knight to B7 he gives up the
pawn as later on he's going to play Rook
to F7 he can bring the other Rook to the
game he can attack the queen with Knight
to C5 he doesn't really need this
doubled pawn and okay Queen captures on
E6 cash captures it Rook to F7 and now
Knight to D4 H putting pressure on the
C6 pawn and uh Here Comes magnus's real
idea and that is Knight to C5 attack ing
the queen on E6 and also threatening
Knight to D3 check to win The Exchange
on E1 but gkes plays Queen captures on
C6 and now Knight to D3 check King to D1
and now not Knight captures on E1 and
Knight captures on E1 if you play this
uh uh right away then the the queen is
undefended so you have to capture the
queen first but even if you capture the
queen first for example Knight captures
on C6 and Knight captures on E1 then
King captures and your down three pawns
yes drop the exchange but you're down
three pawns uh it's not uh really
something so Magnus instead goes for
Knight captures on B2 it is the uh the
better move even better would be Queen
to B8 perhaps uh but Knight captures on
B2 also works we have King to E2 and now
Queen captures on C6 Magnus trades
Queens but Queen to d8 would be uh the
the better way to go Magnus thought okay
I have the exchange uh let's just uh
trade but keeping the tension was the
way to go here he played Queen cap cap
and C6 Knight captures and now Rook to
C8 But Here Comes Pawn to E6 it's the
only move gkes has but it is enough for
him to keep the tension if you go back
with the Knight let's say Knight D4 then
Bishop to H5 check then Rook captures on
C3 and everything falls apart for him
however after Pawn to E6 uh it's not so
easy to play this bishop to H5 check
with have King to E3 now there's no Rook
captures on C3 and Rook to G7 putting
pressure on the G five Pawn we have
Knight to E5 and Rook captures on G5
Rook captures on C3 would be a bit too
dangerous uh allowing King D4 attacking
The Rook the king gets activated and if
you move the Rook then even Knight to E4
with some G4 H4 ideas it's a uh much
much better position uh for gkes so
instead after Knight E5 Rook cap on G5
by Magnus attacking the Knight Here and
Now King to D4 a very very bold play by
gukesh uh Rook to d8 with check Knight
to D7 and now Bishop to G4 uh Bishop to
G4 with some ideas of maybe uh go going
after the pawn right away you can
capture and then after Rook captures you
take out the Knight or maybe you even
prepare it with Rook to G6 so all in all
a very useful move we have uh Rook to E5
now uh makes sense as you are
threatening Rook captures on G5 with
check so Rook to G6 and now Rook to D5
uh point being that if you now capture
the pawn then there's this wonderful
Knight to F6 with check and you blunder
The Rook on d8 so instead after Rook to
D5 King to G7 now comes Knight to E5
attacking The Rook Rook captures on D5
check King captures and now Bishop
captures on E6 with check and this is uh
where Magnus miscalculates a little bit
the correct way to go was Rook captures
on E6 and you don't have to worry about
Knight captures on G4 because there's
Rook to D6 check followed by Rook
captures on uh D2 but after King
captures Bishop captures on E6 with
check was played King to D4 and now Rook
to H6 going after the uh the pawn on H2
but now Rook to B1 attacks the Knight we
have Knight to A4 and now Rook captures
on B5 so you can see how uh White gets
um a lot more activity with with this
line with have Bishop captures an A2 now
comes Pawn to C4 and now gukesh with the
pass C Pawn it's uh it's time to really
come up with a with a you know uh a plan
to defend uh Rook captures on H 2 we
have Knight D to F3 with an attack on
The Rook Rook to H6 and now Rook
captures on A5 attacking the knight uh
Rook to D6 with check King to E3 and now
Knight to C3 you have to also defend the
bishop on A2 but now Rook A3 still
putting pressure on the bishop and the
Knight and now Knight to D1 with check
only way to defend King to E2 and now
Bishop to B1 it it is the only way to
defend but not to defend successfully
it's only the only way to defend uh if
maybe gkes doesn't play the the
strongest moves but he does Pawn to C5
challenges The Rook uh Rook to D5 but
now just Pawn to C6 and uh how do you uh
play this of course you cannot put the
Rook behind the pass Pawn that would
hang the knight uh and uh other moves
don't really uh work Bishop to F5 was
played okay you control the queening
square C7 and now Knight to B2 uh we
have Rook to A2 attacking the Knight on
B2 Knight back to D1 and Rook to C now
preparing to advance the pawn into a
queen so Bishop to C8 you have to play
this uh and now Knight to D3 uh the the
Knight is now uh not defended but okay
even if you capture on D1 also Rook
captures on D3 will happen with check so
King F6 Magnus doesn't have to react to
this and now Rook to C1 threatening Rook
captures on D1 uh Pawn to E5 Magnus
finds a very nice resource and now the
problem is if you capture on D1 then
Pawn to E4 and you're going to pick up
one of those knights with check you're
going to approach the the pawn on C7 and
it will fizzle out into a draw so
instead we have Knight F captures on E5
makes sense uh because if you capture
then uh it's not really an issue uh
Knight to B2 and now Rook to F1 with
check here again uh if you if you
capture on B2 then the Knight on E5 uh
becomes defenseless But Here Comes Rook
to F1 check King to E7 and now Knight to
C6 with check removing the the threat
from of Rook captures on E5 and now
you're just going to win a piece on B2
so King to D6 and only move left to
finish it up is Rook to F6 with check
and of course um uh blocking with the
bishop is pointless because then you
just bring a Queen into the game and the
bishop is spinned so you have to give up
the piece King captures on C7 was played
and now Knight captures on B2 and okay
uh the situation on the clock is 30
seconds for gkes and 40 seconds for
Magnus so maybe he can still hold this
being uh being down a piece uh but it's
going to be very very difficult Bishop
to B7 puts pressure on the Knight Knight
to B4 attacks the rook and now Rook to
H5 and uh you know when when your
opponent has a knight you want your Rook
as far away as possible from your king
but when he has two knights you really
want your Rook you know at at the edge
of the board we have Knight to C4 uh
placing the Knight on C4 next to the
Knight on B4 creates a wall against
magnus's King and now you will start
checking Rook to C7 check will force
uh the king further back and then you
will of course try to Checkmate him uh
we have Rook to H3 going after the pawn
now Rook F7 check King to B8 and Knight
to D6 going after the bishop on B7
Bishop to H1 and now while you're you
probably could play King to F2 to defend
the G3 Pawn H gkes goes for the attack
Knight to A6 with check we have King to
A8 and now Knight to B5 and here uh
there's no defense uh Rook to A7 will
will be Checkmate as the Knight covers
the the B8 square there's nothing more
to be done here and he was in this
position un move 58 that Magnus Carlson
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here uh so you could
prolong it a little bit with something
like Bishop to B7 but after Rook to f8
with check uh there's not much to be
done you're going to have to trade
Bishop for Knight after captures let's
say King B7 Knight to D6 with checking
captures on A6 you will go King F3 uh
and uh yeah you're up a full Knight of
course completely winning so uh Magnus
decided to to give it a rest here uh he
will he will try his luck in some other
games uh so yeah that's the that's the
first game that we've covered uh if you
have any suggestions also do use hashtag
suggestion uh world champion ding Len
had a pretty rough start in the first
three games he uh lost all three uh let
me just check real quickly how he's
doing in the in the fourth
game uh let me
just check it out yeah okay it's still
being played so no update there but we
will jump into the position between but
take us
through but maybe after the rapid event
is over
maybe come come back stronger in CL so
we'll see what happens let's be honest
looked like this already after the
that's the official broadcast yeah just
turned on yeah that's uh because they
have auto play on sorry about that uh
but yeah that's that's the game hope you
guys enjoyed it I would like to thank
Pat iner David Ben Peter aler Robert
taton and David gasparian for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
your wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the chest world uh so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day